本日この母校でお話しさせています
早速なんですけどもまぁちょっと繰り返しなっちゃうっ
みなさんは今まで何種類の肉を食べたことがありますか
u 2鳥ふじ
飛雄馬ちょっとまあ切れ巨匠ね司会のし最近流行ってますよね
それからだチョはに考える人によってはまあ
蛇とかあってい
アルマジロとかキリンとか世界に本当にいろんな肉の選択肢があります
その中で僕が本日ご紹介したいのが
がそうですね
この出そうという動物改めて考えてみるとよく知らないという方が多いんじゃないかな
と思う
改めて打倒にご紹介したいと思います
まず鳥です
世界で一番大きいといいですね結構ですねあの知っているという声がありましたけど
意外と爬虫類だとか方にフィリアとか勘違いする人いるんです
もう行く勘違いされるのが画像ってアフリカの鳥です
オーストラリアの取手署っていう風に感じくださるんですけども大スターなきゃいるの
はエミューですね
まあだぞにかなり近い同じ走鳥類と言うとウソなんですけども
それから大きさ体調が2.3メートル体重が130キロ
かなり大きい時ですよねうみょう40年60年
すごい長生きする通りです
それからたった1年でその2メートルまで成長しますとても成長が早いようですね
繁殖力もたくて年に数十個たと思います
あの答えによっては100個以上可能込むような優秀な答えもいたりします
そんな鳥ですねあの僕先ほど
あのどんどん画像化が進んだ方に立ってるって話をしましたけども
ダチョウ能見さんが40グラムしかないです
すごい期待ですよね相当アホな鳥です
それから目が大きくてまつ毛がなく手足も長い
マートでも号スレンダーな美人ですよね
でそんながそうなんですけども
これからの僕を支える肉になるかもしれないんじゃってかなと思って考えています
でここで改めて
僕自身の自己紹介をさせてください先ほどことがより加藤立つを孝之という名前で活動
させていただきます
肩書きが大3ちぇ万事リストへ
直訳するまあ出そうの伝道師ですね
僕がの先ほど8度初期のたように象つ大学文学部史学科を卒業しそれから
広告会社に就職し
それから2010年の夏にその時の取引先の人と会社をまあ同じ広告とか映像とかを
やるよ会社をつくって
でまぁその会社がまあどんどん甘く順調にメンバーを増えてうまくいきそうだなって
いうふうに住んでいたその版取ったときにある事件が起きます
3 p 11ですね皆さんも狂気に新しいと思います
僕はそのとき渋谷に言いました
守備らにあの渋谷っっあるせきゅりあんとは
あのビルが出身で大きくいうグラグラ口を揺れている様子を見ていました
それからジム戻って
指で
もっと東北の方でもっともっと大変なことになっているということを知ってその日は
もう本当に不安でもう不安な気持ちいっぱいでした
皆さんも同じような経験をされたんじゃないかなと思います
でそれから
詰まっていい言葉しちゃっ
節電この節電の影響でその2010年にうまく順調に進みそうだなと思っていたその
会社の仕事が全部止まってしまい
入っていた分を売り上げの予約も全部キャンセルなってしまった
いつ復旧するか彦三を絶たないこんな状況で
これからどうなっていくんだろう
今何をすべきなんだろという風に悩んでいたところ
そう思っていたところにたまたまなんですけども
南相馬にあの今度行くという形でお会いしましてもうその場で一緒に行かせてください
というふうにと思いました
それで南大隈まで一緒にボランティアでいきまして現地でボランティアをしながら
現地の方に震災の爪痕を実際によるを見せていただいたんですね
これが
海岸から34キロぐらい離れたところの
まあ住宅だったところですねそんなに海から花へというところでもこんなに津波の
ダメージがあった
それからこちらが南相馬の火力発電所ですね
原発のところから木谷さん40kg ところだったと思うんですけども
もうこんなに大きな建物すらもこんなに大ダメージを受けてしまっている
それだけあの津波のダメージが凄まじかったということが見てとれますよね
まあそしてボランティア活動をしているうちしばらくするうちに
ええまあ仕事が復旧したから東京も乗ってくれるようで東京に戻っていったんですけど
もその時に見た光景が頭からどうしても離れなかったんですね
ねそうして東京戻ったところで
自然と人との関わり方であったりこれからの生き方であったり環境コミュニティ経済
シェアという新しい価値観だったりとか
技法者の本当にあの主催により新しい価値観うんというかを大きく価値観の見直しをし
ないといけないんじゃないかなというふうに感じていました
本当にこんな風に世界が変わってしまった状況で自分が今何をすべきなんだろうかって
いうのを考えていたところにたまたま友人のつながりで画像の牧場の形に仕上げました
これ卵ですね大きいですよね
これが親鳥です
これがお肉です今日の主役はその他町中野特にこの子に行くですね
この脱毛の肉初めて食べたところこれがとても美味しかった
それでばそのについてとても気になったのでいろいろ教えてもらったらこれが普及し
たら世界は変わるんじゃないかと言うぐらい大きな可能性を持っているのに全然しら
いけなかっ
皆さんも多分あの今日僕の話を聞くまで知らなかったという方も多いんじゃないかなと
思うんですけども
そういう状況を変えていくべきなんじゃないかなと思ったんですね
そのここからようやく本題に入っていくわけなんですけども attic でしょ
その前に前提として皆さんに共有したいデータがあります
まず皆さんに行くお肉大好きな方が多いんじゃないかなと思うんですけども
それらを生産する過程では多くの資源が必要になります
牛肉で11倍豚肉で7倍
鶏で4倍という風に言われます穀物の狩猟が大量に必要とされます
その過程で
多くの水や土地なども必要となります
例えばその小麦とうもろこしであれば同じ量を生産するのに2000倍の水が必要なる
という風に言われます
それから今現在で現在世界で生産されている国の総量約25億トンというふうに言われ
ていますがまぁと試算されていますがそのうち
8億トンが家畜の餌に回っていますつまり約3分の1が家畜に回っているという現状が
あるんですね
国内の問題に目を向けると食料自給率の問題についてよくニュースとかで取り上げられ
たがそういうことだと思うんですけどもその中で僕が今回取り上げたいのは狩猟自給率
つまり餌の需給率ですね
こちら農水省が出しているデータからの子なんですけども
日本の飼料自給率なんとたったの26%しかないですね
でその餌の自給率皿に分けていくと濃厚飼料自給率
それからと飼料自給率あるんですけどもざっくり言ってしまうと穀物の需給率と木刀系
の需給率というな感じになります
穀物系の自給率たったの12%しかないんですね
一方でと市場の需給は76%という数字です次の問題に行きます
日本では少子化が叫ばへという昨今ですけども
世界に目を向けると
リンクはどんどんどんどん増え続けています2050年には90億人を超える見通しと
いうふうに言われています
このすデータというかこの見通しもどんどんどんどん上方修正されて数字がどんどん
増えて来いってますよね
こうしたことを背景に
食となる穀物を中はどんどん高まっています
このグラフの左はず1970年右味が2014年で40年ぐらいあればですけどもその
40年くらいの間に
だいたいそれぞれ4倍ぐらいあってますねこれ上からお米 daeg 小麦
とうもろこしです
さらにこの水色でくくったところここをクローズアップするとこれ2006年から
2014年なんですけどもこの8年間で2倍になっている
さっき40年で4倍て行ったのがここ8年で2倍ですね
ここ数年だけで上昇曲線とか加速度的にこう上がってきているというところがあります
ですこの加速の背景にある一員としてバイオ燃料への穀物食料の営業ガス指摘されてい
ますね
ほかにもまだまだいろんな問題があり食用機器はすでに起こっている問題という風に
考えるべきなんじゃないかと思っています
このままいくと
食糧危機森林破壊それからに比べ楽なんじゃないかとかいろんなことが言われています
ね
その中であのまあそうした問題解決のために昆虫食を推奨すべきなんじゃないかなと
いう意見も出ています
2013年 fao 黒鉛よう農業機関の報告書の中でもこれからの英
飢餓との戦いにこの辺り上のあたりですね
昆虫食が重要なんじゃないかなということが報告されているわけですね
ここで昆虫食自身がもう行ったほうがいいよとか
あのあれはどうなのかなとか思うという意見は言うつもりはないんですけども
ただここで皆さんに実感していたことは考えたら共感していただきたいのが
食料の選択肢にそういったものを含めて考えるといけない広い視野を持たないといけ
ない時代になってきている
ここだけはも疑いを得ないぞっと状況なんじゃないかなと思っています
そうした中でまぁ数ある選択肢の中で出そうニックが多く呼ばれるなってことでによっ
てこれらの問題が解決していくんじゃないかというところを考えてるんですよて付いて
いくことでしょう
ここまで上げてきた問題を整理すると
まず穀物の需要が高まることによる食糧不足
それから
関連してこの国も増幅する肉も食べられなくなるんじゃないかということそれから穀物
の生産に水や土地などの資源が大量に必要ある
そういうに漆破壊だ水不足など今でも繋がっていくんじゃないかなということがここ
まで挙げた問題でした
そこを出そうにか解決してくるんじゃないかなというところでここからようやく大洞院
といけども付く
これ避けていくんですけども
先ほどの振りから8 o さないで
牛肉は11倍豚肉は7倍じゃあダチョウはというと
3倍です6んですね
3倍というだけでも十分とても少ないんだけどもダチョウはそれ以上のポテンシャルを
持っています
先ほどまでの話で穀物がとにかく課題になっていません
穀物ダチョウはあんまりいらないんです
っていうほとんどいらないと言ってもいいくらいですねじゃあ出そうは何を食べるのか
皆さんちなみにお米小麦とうもろこし食べますよね
立つ桜が食べるものは
アルファルファとか9話とかです
あのまたちょっと皆さんにご質問なんですけどもこの中であるファンさぁたべるよって
いう方がいたら
てあげてください
いますでしょうか
ちょっと見当たらないですかねくま食べるという方いらっしゃいますか
いないですよお一人だまぁこんだけ人数いる中で
を1人しかてやらなかったぐらいつまり皆さんがあんまり食べないものを食べてだと
大きなることができるんですねそれから
こんな雪の中でも育つことができるというのはもともとパパンなの過酷な環境の中で
生き延びてきた動物なんですね
鯖になって昼暑いけど夜寒いんです
その秒あの生命力の強さというところから最近では医療への研究も注目されている
ところですね
エボラ熱の抗体をダチョウの卵を使って抽出することができる作ることができるんじゃ
ないかなという研究もされていたりしています
じゃその肝心の園田層から得られるに行くどんな肉なのか
こんな感じのお肉ですね
これ写真だけ見たら牛肉みたいじゃないですかね
これ食べてみるとですね臭みとか全然ないんです
あのそういう変わった肉って臭いんじゃないのかたいんじゃないのという勘違いされる
方が多いんですけども
画像についてはとても柔らかくて赤身で旨味カッサミがつかないじゃあヒナおります
そのダチョウに行こう
選択する人が
ほとんど増えていくことによって
食糧問題環境問題が緩和されていくんじゃないかなというところが僕は注目集ところ
ですね
そうなるとこれからもおいしいお肉を食べ続けとかできるんじゃないか
それはだぞーに限らず中牛肉も豚肉も鶏肉も諦める必要開いたないかなというふうに
思っています
だらそんなだそうですけどもまだまだ産業としては発展と像です
これ日本生産者とても少ないんですね
生産者が少ないがゆえに立つをさばいてくれる屠殺してくれるところがとても少ない
それからもうそれだけで待っていう量も少ない自然認知もされていないので
食べる方も少ないって言ったところからコストが高くなってしまう供給が不安定だっ
たりする生産者同士の結びつきを弱いので品質が生産者によってものすごくばらつきが
ある
そういった問題が今現像ある中で
僕がやっていることが立つお肉を作る人と食べる人そういったものです
方々がどんどん増えていくことによってダチョウが持っている可能性をより多くの人に
知ってもらって先ほどのようだが問題が解決していくようにしていけたらということが
部活動をしています
今日ここに集まってる皆さんに是非ちょっとあの考えていただきたいのが
押しお肉ヘルシーの食材を探している方
これからも未来にあったライフスタイルを考えている方是非ご提案したような
だそうに食べていませんか
それからいい
愛という土地がある方ん
それから新しい事業を始めたい方未来に向けた活動に取り組みたいというか
だそう牧場やりましょう
最初色の選択にするお話しません
あのはずある選択肢の中で
大像を選ぶことがもしかしたらこれからの世界を変えることになるかもしれない
あなたの選択が世界を変えることにつながるかもしれません
僕は数ある選択肢の中で出すを選びました
皆さんは何を選びますか
僕からの5点はいそうです
ご静聴ありがとうございます